Hoy vamos a ver un tema muy interesante: la pasada semana abordamos el caso de
DONALD TRUMP. Ese hombre de negocios, ese showman que ha convertido la campaña del
Partido Republicano (GOP) en EEUU, la
campaña por la nominación,  en una
auténtica colección de exabruptos,
insultos y delirios.
Sin embargo, aunque, desde la distancia, nos pueda parecer lo contrario, Trump
NO está solo en la carrera por la
nominación.
Así es, Enrique, aunque a algunos les parezca mentira, hay vida más allá de Trump y hoy vamos a
conocer a los otros 4 candidatos
que aspiran a la nominación republicana.
Vamos con ellos!
Desde Nevada, el político con que
más fuerza se ha impuesto a Donald Trump
ha sido el senador Ted Cruz. El senador por Texas en la última legislatura no sólo es uno de los
líderes del partido republicano más
jóvenes sino también uno de los más
conservadores.
Y es que, en esta vorágine, por él extremismo  y en muchos casos el populismo
que ha inundado al partido republicano,
Cruz está dispuesto a liderarlo pero
por la derecha.
De hecho en su campaña por la
nominación se hace acompañar de un
grupo de oración y además pretende
conseguir dicha nominación a la
candidatura a la Casa Blanca por el Partido Republicano con el apoyo
fundamentalmente del voto evangelista.
Pero ¿Porque consideramos que este es uno de los políticos más conservadores?
En primer lugar tenemos que destacar su
oposición, su obsesión, por perseguir la
inmigración ilegal. De hecho, Ted Cruz ha
comprado prácticamente los argumentos
de Donald Trump al respecto. Quiere
deportar a 12 millones de personas,
quiere construir el muro en la frontera
con México en incluso establecer
controles biométricos en los aeropuertos y en todos los accesos al país para que
cuando alguien abandone EEUU
en tiempo y forma, la policía pueda perseguirle.
Por supuesto, multiplicar el
presupuesto de las patruyas fronterizas
pero no sólo es por la inmigración por
lo que que se caracteriza
el conservadurismo de Ted Cruz. Es un
furioso opositor al aborto incluso en casos
de violación, se opone al matrimonio
homosexual y quiere aprovechar cualquier
tipo de resquicio para defender lo que él
denomina la familia tradicional.
Por supuesto no quiere, ni por asomo, que el Estado puede establecer ningún tipo
de limitaciones al acceso a las armas: es un ferviente defensor de derecho a
portar armas. Se opone con todas sus
fuerzas al Obamacare y quiere pegarse
con lo que denominan al cartel de
Washington: aquel el conglomerado formado
por las élites del Partido Demócrata y
Partido Republicano que, en sus propias palabras,
ha secuestrado al pueblo americano bajo una vorágine de impuestos,
regulaciones y limitaciones a la libertad individual.
Y además, es todo un "halcón", el Sr.Cruz.
En política exterior dice que hay que reforzar el
papel de EEUU y lo que el
considera reforzar el papel de EEUU
supone romper el acuerdo nuclear con
Irán, llevar tropas para enfrentarse o
aniquilar, como él mismo dice, al Estado Islámico. Es materia económica
el Sr. Cruz es también
ortodoxo al respecto y, como buen conservador, defiende recortar todo
tipo de gasto que no tenga carácter
militar. Porque aquí sí: también es un
buen republicano y, en línea con esta
vorágine de conservadurismo
o populismo diría yo, que
asola al GOP, quiere
gastar más y más en armas y establecer
lo que él denomina un FLAT TAX, que es un
impuesto único a empresas y
contribuyentes: sean estas personas
físicas o jurídicas. Por cierto: es hijo
de un cubano y nacido en Alberta
(Canadá) lo que ha sido aprovechado por
sus enemigos, sus adversarios políticos
para cuestionar su legitimidad para ser
presidente de los EEUU.
Un político tremendamente conservador que, a pesar de estar mucho más preparado y
ser mucho más coherente que señor
Trump, al fin y al cabo es considerado
un jurista de enorme prestigio, no se queda atrás a la hora de poner propuestas que rompan
con el marco de la política americana.
El siguiente en nuestra lista es MARCO RUBIO.
Bueno, Marcó Rubio también es joven:
tiene 44 años y es un abogado de prestigio.
Actualmente es senador por el
estado de Florida. Como decimos, un tipo
brillante. De hecho, bueno. 2012 cuando
Romney se posicionó para ser el candidato republicano,
uno de los que barajó para
hacer Vicepresidente con él fue Marco Rubio.
Políticamente hablando hay que
reconocer que ha sido el tío un poco "veleta".
Fue uno de los 8 autores del proyecto de reforma de ley para tratar de
conseguir la ciudadanía a los 11
millones de inmigrantes sin papeles en
EEUU  y luego, pues se salió de ese proyecto. También se metió en el
TEA PARTY cuando aquélla empezaba a
crecer en 2010 y de hecho, algunos
latinos... había pancartas que
decían:
"Marco Rubio: latino o teapartino" es decir, que se aclare.
El es de origen cuban: sus padres son cubanos y él siempre dijo, en su día, que
sus padres emigraron a EEUU
por motivo de Fidel Castro. Luego
se descubrió que eso NO era cierto. Que sus padres habían emigrado
antes de que Fidel Castro llegara al poder,
es decir, que huyeron de la dictadura de BATISTA
Eso le causó un gran desgaste y lo que hizo fue pedir perdón y
contratar a un detective para que
tratara de de buscar la verdad.
Dijo que le ayudó a conocer su su propia
historia.
Se declarara católico, fervientemente católico, pero cuando vivía
en Las Vegas, con 13 años, con su su familia, les dijo "oye... por qué no
vamos a Iglesia mormona que están ahí todos mis amigos y me parece muy interesante".
Parece que no le gustó mucho. A su abuelo le intentó llevar
pero eso de que no se podía fumar y beber no le hace mucha gracia y bueno...
al final le dijo a dijo su familia "pues no pasa nada... volvemos a la Iglesia católica"...
No lo estoy criticando por ello pero... es un dato, desde luego, muy, muy curioso.
El siguiente candidato en esa lista es
JOHN KASICH: el actual gobernador de
Ohio y el que muchos consideran como
el candidato más moderado de estas
elecciones. Y digo de estas elecciones
porque tradicionalmente ha
sido considerado muy conservador.
A diferencia de de sus contrincantes que
sí sí tiene experiencia en la gestión política.
Desde 2011 es Gobernador del Estado de Ohio. Su política económica se
sustenta en congelar el gasto de
carácter no militar sobre todo el gasto
social: hacer una redistribución de partidas cuando se necesiten recursos.
Y bajar los impuestos.
De hecho, ha sido conocido el cambio que ha realizado en el estado de Ohio,
donde no sólo consiguió terminar
con un déficit de 8.000 millones de dólares
sino mismo tiempo bajó los
impuestos en casi 5.000 millones.
Además, a diferencia de sus
contrincantes, es partidario de una
reforma migratoria que otorgue el
derecho a estar en EEUU a los
inmigrantes ilegales. Es decir,
regularizarles. En política exterior,
no quiere romper el pacto con Irán. El
considera que fue negativo.
No es partidario de la negociación de Obama y la ha reprobado pero dice que una vez firmado,
hay que respetarlo. Es un buen aliado de
Israel y tienes planteamientos mucho
más moderados aún siendo muy conservador. Probablemente si el marco político de EEUU
y del GOP fuese distinto, Kasich hubiese
tenido muchas posibilidades de ser
candidato a la presidencia. Sin embargo
hoy hay quien dice que sólo
continua la carrera para conseguir la
nominación a Vicepresidente.
Y para terminar nuestro último
candidato es Ben Carson.
Ha pasado por las primarias creando bastante expectación porque, como Donald Trump,
no tiene experiencia política alguna y sus
declaraciones han sido un tanto polémicas.
Sus posiciones políticas no son tan radicales como las de otros candidatos.
Él no está por deportar a inmigrantes como pueden estar
otros candidatos. No es no está a favor
del Obamacare.
Está totalmente en contra de cualquier vestigio de sanidad pública
en EEUU. Sus posición, de todas maneras, ha ido decreciendo.Empezó muy fuerte
y ha habido muchas filtraciones sobre él pero al final ha resultado ser un poco "bluf".
Está esperando a ver qué pasa el "supermartes" y algunos se atreven a decir, incluso, que bueno, pues...
De momento está a ver si puede vender
algún libro, que nunca está de más...
Pues, como hemos dicho, aún no hay nada decidido y hay que esperar
todavía para saber quién va a ser
finalmente nominado.
Si va a ser Trump, Cruz, Rubio, Carson, Kasich, no lo sabemos...
Hay que esperar al Supermartes que tenemos por delante el día 1 de marzo
y bueno... es cierto que al día 15, el 15 de marzo, podremos saber si Trump es finalmente derrotado.
Si le echan de la carrera.
Cosa que yo personalmente espero.
Si tienes cualquier duda, cualquier comentario, por favor, no dudéis en hacerlo.
¡Nos vemos en el próximo vídeo!